So I mentioned earlier this week that there's
something palpable in the air that feels different
since Joe Biden won the presidential election,
even though Joe Biden is not yet the president,
just something feels like we're starting to
have a shot at no longer being a laughing
stock globally and getting back on a better
path.
And it's sort of a vague thing, but there's
something not vague that is very quickly changing,
which is that the world is starting to ignore
Donald Trump.
There's still months until Joe Biden is actually
inaugurated as president of the United States.
And even though Donald Trump has refused to
concede the election and is talking about
legal fights and lawsuits, and he really won
and all of this stuff, the world is already
dealing with Joe Biden as the adult in the
room and is starting to just ignore Donald
Trump.
And it is extremely triggering for Donald
The Biden transition team is moving along.
Biden launched his own coronaviruses task
force.
They've already met.
World leaders are calling Joe Biden and talking
to him about the future.
Boris Johnson said he spoke to Joe Biden and
it was refreshing.
But on the other side of the equation, you
are seeing Donald Trump just being ignored.
Earlier in the week, Fox News cut away from
his press secretary, Kayleigh McEnany.
That was, I think, Monday for wildly repeating
baseless voter fraud allegations.
They're just tired of it.
The leaders of major allies like Germany and
the United Kingdom and Israel have congratulated
and welcomed Joe Biden.
Joe Biden has announced key appointments and
they're being dealt with by the serious media
as appointments by a president elect, not
some guy who hasn't really won.
This applies to the coronavirus task force.
Joe Biden's selection yesterday, the day before
yesterday, of Ronald Klain as chief of staff.
So this is not the world that Trump wants
to be real, but it is real and media outlets
are covering it.
World leaders are now dealing with Biden.
Many Trump staffers are privately saying the
entire contesting the election thing is pointless.
Courts have so far found all of Donald Trump's
various legal challenges to be completely
spurious and without merit.
And social media platforms are also more aggressively
flagging Donald Trump's completely unhinged
posts as election related misinformation.
Look at newspapers around the world.
After reporting the election results, newspapers
have moved on from Trump.
Newspapers around the world are discussing
Joe Biden's possible cabinet, Joe Biden's
possible foreign policy.
How would a Joe Biden presidency affect our
relationship, meaning these other countries
relationships with the United States?
And the contrast is just stunning.
Trump is tweeting that he won stuff and suing
people while Joe Biden announces policy advisors,
staffers and more.
Trump tweets, bogus voter fraud, conspiracy
theories.
What?
Meanwhile, Biden's holding a coronavirus task
force meeting.
So let's keep the focus on moving forward.
Let's not indulge the possibility that there
will be any other outcome.
But at the same time, let's remember that
there are, what, seventy one seventy 72 million
people that voted for Donald Trump.
Many of them like to moonlight as militia
members.
Many could spill out into the streets if this
continues.
And what we have to hope for as Trump fires
people and has who knows what up his sleeve.
If anything, we have to hope that our institutions
are more solid than a few people, that Trump
is moving around during the transition.
And once we get past it, we get past it and
it's over unless Trump runs in twenty, twenty
four.
But we're not even dealing with that right
now.
So again, Trump threatening to leave the country
if he loses, saying it's rigged, filing lawsuits,
firing dissidents or even people not completely
on board with what he says.
These are all actions that around the world
we've seen done by some pretty bad people
over the last 100 plus years.
But in the end, Trump is going to go now.
One other thing, Donald Trump has not been
taken totally seriously by the media and leaders
of many countries.
His entire presidency, folks who never look
at foreign coverage of Trump may not know
this, but Donald Trump was not taken seriously
by the newspapers and media outlets of many
countries.
Trump has been ignored now for years.
In many areas, climate and others.
Trump has been one of the least covered US
presidents in Europe in a long time because
he's been a joke.
So for some countries, it's not that they're
talking about Biden instead of Trump, they
just weren't talking about Trump.
They're going back to talking about an American
president as someone that they can work with,
as someone that they can actually deal with
in a reasonable way.
That's a very good thing for the United States.